die in ramberg naja ich kann nicht mehr
ich will hier den berg einwohner kommen
ja nur tolle brücke durch meine lieben
freund und herzlich willkommen hier zur
ersten folge von minecraft galaxy jetzt
auch auf meinem kanal die folge kamen
nicht gestern weil es da probleme mit
dem upload gab deswegen habe ich die
folge dann nochmal gelöscht und dieses
vor intro dingsbums als erklärung noch
mal davor gepackt es dürfen eigentlich
nicht zwei folgen täglich kommen es wird
allerdings jetzt heute für mich eine
ausnahme gemacht weil es uns doch wäre
da ich schon ein paar folgen aufgenommen
hat mit anderen leuten und das wäre dann
durch wenn die folgen bei den anderen
leuten nur einen tag vorm einer folge
dann kommen würden deswegen kommen heute
bei mir zwei minecraft galaxy folgen die
erste seht ihr ja gerade die zweite
kommt heute abend irgendwann und dann
würde ich sagen sorry für das kommt
nicht wieder vor und ab jetzt jeden tag
weiter galaxy heute part 1 & 2 und
morgen part 3 und dann würde ich euch
sagen viel spaß mit euch gefällt last
auf jeden fall ein daumen hoch da und
dann würde ich sagen viel spaß
vielleicht nicht im video
minecraft die herzliche kopf zu einem
weiteren wundervollen epischen
hoffentlich epischen projekte bisher
noch nicht ich meine es ist konkreter
dabei also nicht verpassen
ja also wir spielen hier ein
wundervolles schönes neues bike ich
schon mal auf den server und es sind
drei menschen mit dabei in dieser
aufnahme konstellation und schwarz einen
ist es derzeit zudem zu dem er zudem
zudem endlich zu dem k
mit hd also ein klavier wettbewerb war
aufgefallen dass wirklich dass eine
völlig überdrehte begrüßung war aber ein
haben oder gar nicht erwähnt den hab ich
dir in kontakt ist auch dabei der sack
voller wein und bei mir hat auch alles
wie sau mit shader und alles ich möchte
erstmal ganz kurz hier in der ersten
folge sagen hallo wir sind alle mit
dabei das ist mein gegenüber wir spielen
attack of the beat ihm das ist ein
tpeg wo sehr sehr sehr sehr viele mods
dabei sind also wir haben hier eine
immens da ist ein da sind so was von
vielen muss dabei also wirklich ganz
anders als bei wo wir gar nichts dabei
hatten hier ist eine menge dabei ihr
seht schon hier zehn millionen neue
items und hier so blöcke und alles und
wir sind hier gerade um einen wir haben
mehrere fraktionen aber ich muss sagen
da redet maximal 94 seiten durch ok also
granie erklärt jetzt blue card guard
schon erklärt und jetzt erklärt kann ich
noch mehr denn es ist ein traum dult ich
wirklich keinen kompromissen die
meisterung von motta von den mods meine
mittellange hand haben wir dieses
wunderschöne projekt geplant und ja es
gibt zwei fraktionen und zwar einmal das
team foxtrott jetzt mit also ja ich rein
das ist nämlich genau wer so die
coolsten boys am block und nicht nur wir
vier sind noch ganz ganz viele andere
und guckt euch einfach mal an ich wäre
es ein skelett jungs könnt mich mal an
schlag ist machbar wenn ich denke wie
ich in vivi kannst du das dann gleich
mal auszugleichen ich zu so einem
skelett laufen kannst ja treffens keller
töten in der maus arbeiten würden aber
jungs flaches produktiv sein wir müssen
ja ich bin nicht 100 bei magath scheint
sachen zu machen er ist ein bisschen weg
laufen von der basic er auch dafür da
wir uns als irgendwo anders hin wollen
ich hatte nicht so bockig in diese
region hier ist so geil ich hab mir
schon platz ausgesucht ich weiß schon wo
ich hin will
ich habe jedoch sprung macht auch einige
oder sprung konnten hinterher ich bin
ich weiß schon wo ich hin hallo hallo
dort wo gehen wir dann ab dem moment ich
hab nämlich schon was gespottet wo ich
hin will ja wo ist ja ob moment du musst
einfach nach links vom haus in die diese
mega schlucken
da kommt was übrigens beim so nebenbei
und die wichtigste sache für alle
zuschauer zu erklären ja es gibt wieder
eine todes regel allerdings ist es nicht
so dass ein tod bedeutet dass man gleich
aus dem projekt draußen ist sondern es
ist wieder so wenig über hero sobald man
stirbt muss man einen tag mit einer
folge aussetzen also es irgendwie kein
richtiges drama aber es ist noch ein
bisschen lockerer man muss dem ich nicht
irgendwie noch ein grabstein zug medien
wieder beleben sondern er darf respawn
wenn er gestorben ist das gar kein ding
und die folge dann ganz regulär beenden
aber dann konnte am nächsten tag darauf
ist upload sparrate das was ist wenn die
person dann noch mal steht in der folge
dann ist sie tot
dann ist sie tot aber im regelfall nicht
beendet hat seine bücher ein rotes
normaler sich die muster direkt weinend
die aufnahme verlassen und die musste
ich einen release umbringen ich habe
keine bücher weil ich getötet wurde
einfach mal muss getötet werden getötet
kri wie lp glaube ich dieser brauch ich
habe mir erst mal das haus markiert von
unserem
von unserem von unseren game sag ich mal
die will ich an ort und stelle auch
machen das ist wirklich sehr schlau ist
markiert
danke martin unglaublich ich weiß auch
nicht wie im blick dass wir nicht gleich
irgendwie wieder also übrigens folgen
mäßig soll so in etwa immer so 15
minuten kommen gibt es eine strafe man
über zieht man kriegt aufs maul ich habe
eine schlucht gefunden werden wenn
jemand bock hat dann kann er zu mir
kommen wo seid ihr denn alle diese
karten ich möchte meine pace ubs auf m
sonnig und dann willst du rechtsklick
und dann kannst du erwarten nennen mag
möchtest du so einen kleinen einblick
für die zuschauer die komplette team
nicht kennen geben was denn sowieso
alles noch machbar ist
rainman features sind natürlich also
attack of the team ich kann euch mal die
coolsten sachen und sage ich mal
vorstellen
sky mit dem webos richtig cool effect of
two pi team wieder halt einfach krass
viele möglichkeiten noch mehr als es
jetzt zum beispiel und herztod
nein nein wehrt sich daraufhin rund 82
war so hätte aber irgendwelche ist wie
problems oder so es wird am rauchen
theater und fernsehen ich dann irgendwie
auf den disconnect button gekommen bist
du ja wir sind auch gut wir starten
extra die aufnahme zu 500 verpiss dich
jeder irgendwie irgendwann luca luka wir
gehen in die schlucht und das ist eine
sehr gute quali dateneingabe bei luca
luka wir gehen hier in die schlucht da
sind richtig coole sachen drin
vielleicht wären wir ein paar das schon
was findet ihr euch gerade erst mal
gucken wo ich mich hin baue ich hab
schon ich habe das ja schon ihr könnt
nach alle zu mir zu besuch kommen aber
seiten hin also ich glaub ich nicht
darin die wand bauen sondern der sonne
ich glaube das mache ich es warum
existiert
daraus kann man sich im eisen schmerzen
ganz einfach es ist also es sind
wirklich sehr sehr viele daran zugefügt
man kann auch diese das restaurant ist
schon ganz gut gefallen
der gegner mega ab im mega projekt und
man kann halt eben diese sachen auch
machen das macht das natürlich schafft
es drauf bildkraft glaube ich nie also
wobei der kreis nicht auf jeden fall was
mit pipes und autokraten und so also da
wird einiges gehen
und ja ein paar coole sachen einfach das
liebig also ist was so geil ist das ist
das ist wirklich cooler als alles andere
was es gibt man kann sich einfach in
minecraft galaxy in attack of the beat
ihm kann man sich waffen kräften ihr
könnt hier mit einer ecke herum laufen
und einfach die ganzen anderen [ __ ]
abschießen
ein bisschen waffen anschauen das ist
jetzt ein bisschen mit gta verwechselt
kann der 1
niemand kann sich aber auch panzer und
autos bauen glaube ich zwar keinen papa
man kann sich auch so titanen bauen den
man dann auf dem boden hier ich möchte
erstmal schön ausbauen
diesmal lieber ein panzer im haus nimmt
ihr schon auf st
den quatsch bullshit ich will spaß zu
haben
man kann übrigens mal sehen sind nicht
alle leute open service aber ein paar
also sind wieder viele menschen dabei
die sind natürlich alle allesamt in der
schweiz trifft ja genau alles in dem
spiel natürlich erst unser wunderschönes
system und ja das ist richtig sexy
übrigens hat gerade echt schöne haare
das möchte man ja dann könnte könnte
daher findet auch sein canada zaba
schöneres traum ja also wäre doch
immerhin kriegt das blut das raster oder
oder ein haar wachs das milieu kommt
waffe gezeigt hatte
ich kenne ja lukas im urlaub und er hat
mir damals diesen starbucks bezahlt und
ich habe von der ersten fällt mir dazu
brauche ich will auch so cool sagen die
kraft und das war dann so der beweggrund
dass ich das auch in münster
das war aber sexurlaub scheiße ja ja
genau das was zum teufel ist sogar an
sterben sonnig ich bin eine spinne
geworden
wenn du drückst und lacht und dann nach
oben dann kann ich hab das ich glaub ich
hab einfach die geilste wohnung ich
wohne einfach so im märz kann auf alles
drauf gucken dass wir das so 11 uhr
lasst uns mal bitte zueinander bauen
moment wenn ich bin immer noch dabei
mich auf dem weg was ist im zweifel es
ist ziemlich weit weg wo ich hin muss
deswegen weil eine schöffin schwimmen
ich bin bei 13 bis neun spielen kein
spiel mehr denn wenn ihr euch in
skateboard oder sowas dann könnt ihr
team tisch briten ich bin mir bitte
bitte wieder mit ja ich habe das gefühl
gehabt hab ich einfach richtig bock dann
rollt fliegen kann jetzt ruhig hatten es
diebe auffliegen
ich habe eine fledermaus gefunden und
getötet junge luca komm zurück zum
schluss zurück erst noch eine fledermaus
nein ich bin noch heute mein spiel kenn
ich bin arm sein
ich kann das gar nicht ein pilz werden
ich kann in der ersten folge schon
fliegen alter wie geil ist das denn
übrigens so nebenbei zu informationen
ich glaube dass jetzt ein hexenhaus oder
so ich glaube bin und jetzt leute habe
ich mein ziel erreicht denn ich werde
auf einer wunderschönen fliegenden insel
der hausbank was ist das für eine geile
ersten folge ich kann
gegen und hatten später ich daraus lerne
immer direkt mir vorbei fliegen wenn du
geld ich habe so eine schule in jedes
ich sehe dich ewig an uns liegen endlich
guck mal cooper coupé heinrich
du kannst eine wand hochlaufen recht
schnell warst du mal mit relativ fallen
jetzt einfach der iggensbacher links die
gamer allerdings weiter links jetzt
jetzt jetzt zu mir zu mir zu weit rechts
und bisschen höher stehen vom berg ja ja
ich sehe dich seh ich kann nicht mehr
ich freue mich euch hier den berg
einwohner kommen ja nur tolle brücke
irgendwie zu einer wäre toll zu sehen
was dann auch ja genau das funktioniert
auch ja das habe ich werde irgendwie
maschine mit einer bürste du siehst aus
wie eine stinknormale spinne aber du
hast du hast dir deine rüstungsbetriebe
sprung schlendern über dir darüber
stehen was heißt hier nicht deshalb
haben wir uns überlegt dass für für pvp
zu verbieten erwartet als spinne die
welt so großaspach
ich bin eine fledermaus ticker das ist
so cool alter das ist wirklich feuer
gleich einen leeren akku li und ich
finde ihn gekommen es sich irgendwie mit
mit tieren ich dachte enthält aber nein
ich bin eine spende ich kann einfach in
so ein blog höher sachen ein wichtiger
akzent hotel alter ich freue mich voll
mein haus schon voll cool
maximilian isenberg drin es kommt so
alter die meisten für doch wird er ich
habe noch einen balken 1 sterben hätte
es mehr habe man zu mir sagst du diesen
berg wo du fackeln drin
und da will man hunger hat stellt man
dann ich guck mal luca und stetig mit
dem nicht wenn du nicht siehst ich sehe
dich doch leider nicht lukas glaube
nicht dass du stirbst aber du bist halt
runter irgendwie gebildet oder so nicht
hinnehmen ich schwöre ich wenig hoch
volumen und da ist kein kein süßer
kleiner kompakter in der nähe
ich bin in sonnenberg und da so wackelt
ach ja ich seh dich okay ich komme luca
aber ich mag mich nicht wenn du mich
siehst
ich weiß gerade eben nicht so wirklich
genossen
heute kann man sterben und hunger in
swaps nein wir sind nicht auf hardcore
fan okidoki nicht wenn du ziehst 25
vielleicht und liebevoll für leben
beiden hunger
ja es ist entspannt ich hab ich kann
einfach in der ersten folge fliegen er
jedoch zweimal blieben wegen hunger wie
www sternen hunger du hast dir dass du
hast jetzt bauen was markiert oder
kannst du zurückkommen dann gebt ihr
zeug
ich bin gegen hunger da ich fast alles
auf hast du das bauernhaus markiert der
dann kommt zurück ich geb dir was ich
stelle den hunger gewissens ihr könnt
schaffst du es ist baum selbst falls ich
kann fliegen in der ersten folge kann
die stadt nur halb so schön rein
so wird zum start einfach max die
koordinaten max liegt gut zu dir herr zu
dir hin
ich kann ich nach gröden nachdem pflegen
behinderte mir leid ich kann das echt
nicht so leicht
also ich habe schon einen richtig kommt
im haus vorher ich bin auch ein bisschen
eisen gerüstet aber jetzt weiß ich eben
nicht so genau ob ich hier wieder runter
gehen soll oder nicht einfach voller
waren die gegendemonstranten gebt mir
mal eure sachen gehabt ich hab gar
nichts dann bist du da ich bin
erleichtert zehn sekunden
ich komme aus geflogen ich bin einfach
so schnell was nicht der fall
ich komme ich kann mich mal wir müssen
auch gleich auch jetzt ist das doch
völlig raus müssen gleich die folge
beenden oder also ist das scheiße hier
mit einem erhalten herz aus spinne ich
sehe kaum was wo bist du bist du oben
spielen können 18
ja ich sehr gut an 18 dieser falsch ich
habe glaube ich kann heute sowieso so
willst du jetzt schön das chaos ins live
erleuchtet da oben katy sind im moment
gehe ich noch mal gucken ob ich sehe
aber die kleinen laufen aber morgen
lieber wechsels töten ich würde eine
spinne bist du auf dich lieber weg also
ich werfe hier ein paar äpfel hin und du
kannst aber auch an anderen laster ab
warum sache ist halt auch einfach wir
müssen nicht also es ist jetzt nicht so
ja wer sich nicht an 15 minuten upload
hält der fliegt raus sondern es wäre
schön wenn man so wirklich im rahmen von
15 minuten bleiben könnte
deswegen versuchen wir das hier auch
gerade deswegen habe ich auch sagen dass
wir jetzt einfach jetzt schon mal alle
runter gehen ein schönes ende finden
ja das habe ich mal wieder so geht's
einfach runter weil ich will dich vor
erste folge nicht überziehen ich fand
das war ein super start ich hab schon
super plötzlich auf irgendwas anderes
von uns auf jeden fall so eine coole
brücke hängen ja wir stehen ja erst mal
gewalt auf jeden fall gefallen als bitte
eine bewertung dar
und natürlich sagen wir können uns ja
auch tipps etc in die kommentare
schreiben da will ich sagen tschüss von
meiner seite aus